et elle était venue nous raconter le
terrible cambriolage dont elle a été
victime quelques mois plus tôt Coraline
était en train de se filmer pour les
réseaux quand les cambrioleurs sont
arrivés regardez
[Musique]
ça
alors merci Coraline d'être avec nous
donc un homme s à votre porte vous
agresse violement rappelez-nous ce qui
s'est passé ouais en fait c'est un un
jeune homme qui a sonné à la porte
j'avais le judas j'ai regardé un jeune
homme donc je me suis dit bon ok j'ai
ouvert il m'a dit que céit un de mes
voisins je ne les connais pas tous donc
j'ai ouvert la porte il m'a demandé de
l'aluminium je suis allé chercher l'
l'aluminium dans la cuisine et en fait
quand j'ai pris l'aluminium j'ai senti
qu'il y a quelque chose qui était pas
normal et en venant sur mes pas il
m'attendait dans un salon il m'a pris à
la gorge et il a essayé de me enin il
m'a tabassé pour que je tombe déjà et
puis il m'a il voulait ma montre alors
euh là il dévalise ils vous ont dévalisé
dévalise votre votre dressing c'est ça
ouais en fait il cherche ma montre dans
mon dressing était devant ses yeux et il
l'a même pas vu et puis dansun moment je
leur dit mais qu'est-ce que vous voulez
je suis all leur chercher Maan je leur
ai donné main dans la main ils ont pris
mon portable qui était en train de
tourner ils sont partis en me fermant
dans le dans dans le dressing alors vous
avez des des affaires assez de grandes
marques dans votre dressing ou pas mais
pas forcément plus les montrer sur
TikTok c'est peut-être pour ça qu'il est
venu aussi est-ce que c'est sur insta
plus que ce que tout mais oui non je
monre j'ai pas beaucoup de choses enfin
j'ai des choses que j'aime bien mais
c'est pas des
choses si luxueuse que ça c'est
peut-être des trucs de marque et est-ce
qui c'est pas c'est pas vos vidéos qui
ont fait que les personnes son ouais je
pense que c'est sur bien mon compte
Instagram à mon avis par que la montre
je la portais depuis presque 10 ans en
fait donc je faisais pas attention
d'accord aujourd'hui c'est vrai que on
en parlait il a un instant avec Greg
est-ce que aujourd'hui lu vous êtes vous
êtes traumatisé par ce qui s'est passé
est-ce que vous videz bien sûr B c'est
la même chose moi dès que j'ai quelqu'un
qui me suit dans la rue cagoule ou pas
enfin casque ou pas casque enfin
n'importe quelle personne j'ai peur tous
les hommes alors on a l'impression
Michel parce que c'est vrai que il est
21h5 il y a beaucoup beaucoup de gens
qui réagissent sur cette séquence les
vols à main armé se multiplient de fou
en ce moment et donc justement pour les
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent c'est
c'est incroyable oui il y a une recrud
d'esence de ce type de criminalité là
depuis quelques mois je vais juste faire
une une toute petite observation sur les
les deux les deux situations dans
lesquell auxquelles vous avez été
confronté je pense qu'à chaque fois ils
ont été repérés vous c'est le Tmax alors
pardon excusez-moi je vous coupe
attendez je vous coupe 30 secondes je ne
fais plus de story moi c'est-à-dire
maintenant où je vais non mais je vous
parle pas de vous je vous parle de votre
scooter oui mais mon
SC les Tmax c'est l'engin le plus
volé donc il y a eu un repérage c'est
pas vous qui cherchez c'est votre
scooter et après ils ont vu que c'était
vous tout ce que voulais
dire mon scooter attendez je vous coupe
30 secondes mon scooter ok d'accord il
est volé mais c'est un scooter que j'ai
acheté d'occasion il même pas
neuf on vous a vu avec c'est tout vous a
repéré avec le scooter et ils sont ven
chercher deavir le scooter ilér avec le
scooter en fait et en fait ce qui se
passe c'est qu'après ils ont été étonnés
que ce soit lui à tu vois c'est ça c'est
exactement ça et et vous effectivement
c'est à peu près pareil vous avez été vu
avec cette montre sur les réseaux et ils
sont venus ils vous ont identifié logé
et ils sont venus vous donc pour revenir
à la recrue d'essence on a aujourd'hui
une criminalité organisée euh qui a un
petit peu modifier sa sa sa trajectoire
avant on le disait l'autre fois c'est
les braquages de fourgons les braquages
de banquees tout ça c'est terminé et le
homejcking alors il y a différentes
formes il y a le cambriolage simple il y
a le homejcking et il y a encore dans
l'hjcking des des variantes lui il a eu
donc lui il a eu les deux lui he ah moi
j'ai deux ouais vous avez eu les deux
mais je je lisais le ENF je voyais une
une autre une affaire absolument
incroyable où des gens étaient chez eux
d'ailleurs le gang a été démenté de
écoutez bien ça ouais le la personne est
chez elle avec sa femmes ses enfants ses
chiens il est dans une magnifique maison
des Yvelines et les hommes jacquer l'ont
gazé c'est qu'ils sont rentrés à
l'intérieur du domicile ils ont
probablement ils avaient des masques sur
le visage ils ont répandu un gaz
soporifique à l'intérieur du bâtiment
son impossible les gens pardon c'est
mission impossible quoi c'est pas
mission impossible c'est c'est une vraie
histoire très fréqument ça et c'est
arrivé c'est arrivé c'était dans les
ivelines et les individus ont pour la
plupart d'ailleurs été interpr il
volaient les voitures des voitures de
luxe des des des des grosses des grosses
berlines des grosses des gros 44 donc la
la criminalité n'arrête jamais en
réalité il y a toujours un un plus du
plus et donc ils améliore à chaque fois
leur leur mode opératoire c'est une
expression parce qu'il voulait dire
mission impossible
euh ça c'est une expression euh oui
juste un chiffre qui va faire frémir les
gens mais c'est le dernier chiffre 1000
agressions par jour sont commises en
France 1000 agressions par jour 362000
en 2023 voilà plus 6 % donc voilà là ça
c'est global 63 % par rapport en 2017 en
2017 c'était que 220000 donc c'est c'est
bien pire voilà donc c'est énorme il y a
une hausse de l'insécurité parfois le
gouvernement nous dit c'est le sentiment
de sécurité non il y a une hausse les
chiffres sont là euh juste pour revenir
toutes les histoires parce que les
histoires de de de people on a
l'impression que toutes les semaines il
y a un pipole qui se fait qui se fait
cambrioler ou agresser ou qu'est-ce qui
se passe il se passe que ces gens sont
en vue que ces gens sont repérés euh on
je vous le disais l'autre l'autre jour
euh par le système des de de de
plateforme de livraison
euh il y a des information qui circulent
il y a des équipes extrêmement
structurées un peu comme dans le grand
banditisme où on a des équipes à tiroir
et donc on va euh dès qu'il récupère une
adresse le nom le le code et cetera via
un livreur et ben ils envoient ils
envoient du monde sur sur ces affaires
et ils viennent ils viennent braquer ou
et en même temps les peines sont
relativement faibles c'est ça c'est ça
le problème gre tu te fais tu te fais
menacer toi insulter sur les réseaux ou
pas ah oui complet ouais oui bien sûr
les les les haurs c'est courant on va
dire mais moi alors d'aujourd'hui je je
calcule même pas ça ouais ça parce que
je me dis que dans ma tête déjà que le
mec déjà il prend de l'énergie pour
m'écrire et pour m'insulter déjà oua
déjà j'ai gagné déjà parce que le mec il
a mis une minute dans sa vie pour
m'écrire une insulte mais pour qui
m'écrit une insulte il a réfléchi il a
pensé il a Gaspé de l'énergie il a pris
son clavier il a écrit donc du coup
alors d'aujourd'hui moi les qui me je
les aime autant c'est pas c'est pas
grave mais justement on a parlait des
des menaces que vous avez reçu tous ici
Jacques je sais que toi ça tu reçois
beaucoup de choses et c'est vrai qu'on
en avait parlé la dernière fois c'est
vrai que mais moi la la menace la plus
importante c'était pas sur les réseaux
c'était début de saison lorsqu'on
parlait beaucoup du conflit
israëlo-pestinien et que dès qu'on dit
quelque chose blanc les gens pensent que
on est antioir d qu'on dit quelque chose
noir on est antiblanc et bon comme
c'était une période où on avait pris la
parole après à la suite de l'attaque du
7 octobre et que il y avait un droit
pour Israël à se défendre forcément j'ai
j'ai j'ai été voilà j'étaé pris à parti
par quelqu'un qui
voulait voilà qui m'a dit attention à ce
que tu dis sur la Palestine et qui m'a
fait des signes qui étaient pas très pas
très agréable mais bon on est dans un
monde aujourd'hui où dès l'instant où on
dit quelque chose les gens pensent que
ça veut dire qu'on pense exactement le
enfin que tous les gens qui sont contre
cet avis là sont forcément vos ennemis
c'est pas le cas Raymon toi pour non moi
aussi moi aussi sur les réseaux ça
m'arrive aussi de de de manger comme les
comme les collègues parce qu'on est en
direct on dit ce qu'on pense donc pareil
que jacqu au moment du conflit les gens
ont dit ouais tu es tu es pour tu es
pour les Juifs après le lendemain bah
j'étais pour j'étais pour la Palestine
ça mélange un peu tout donc c'est des
menaces de mort je vais t'égorger je va
je vais venir à devant canal Factory je
vais moi ça fait un peu comme lui moi je
m'en fous si tu prends énergie à
m'écrire prendre l'énergie à m'écrire je
passe auudessus de ça les toutes ces
menaces tout ça je m'en fous les même
les cambriolages qui qui a un témoignage
fort qui a eu a eu HUG après il y a
aussi par rapport juste à ce qu'on est
pas uniquement par rapport à ce qu'on
dit euh moi souvent ce que ce que je
reçois c'est des menaces de mort qui
sont principalement d à à mon
orientation c'estd que vraiment c'est
très précis on me dit comment on va me
tuer on me dit qu'on va m'égorger on me
dit que on va tuer ma famille parce que
quand il y a quelqu'un comme moi dans
une famille toute la famille mérite de
mourir voilà je reçois vraiment des
messages où tu dis la personne elle a
étudié le sujet et et c'est c'est c'est
complet donc voilà c'est c'est très
violent et je pense que pour certaines
personnes qui enfin ça doit être très
très difficile moi ça va moi ça va je
tiens moi j'envie Raymond et Greg mais
moi je passe pas oututre c'est-à-dire
que moi ça a changé ma vie les menaces
et encore une fois je ne fais pas là du
Patos me plaindre on a une personnalité
publique on a une très belle vie
attention mais moi ça a changé ma vie
c'estàdire que maintenant voilà je sors
plus je me cache hisire de vie peut-être
que toi par non mais attends laisse
laisse le témoigner non non je dis juste
c'est pas du tout une critique hein je
dis juste moi ça a influé sur mon
comportement j'ai changé je suis fermé
je ris moins j'ai c'est les menaces
elles m'ont fait peur et les plaintes
n'ont pas effacé les menaces Michel non
je veux juste te dire que c'est une
forme de terrorisme et ces gens
parviennent à leur fin précisément à
partir du moment où ils font peur où ils
vous empêchent de sortir où c'est du
terroris
et et d'autant plus que ça influe sur
les débats suivants et ça peut
influencer le positionnement qu'on peut
avoir c'est très important parce que la
forme de terrorisme don à laquelle tu
fais allusion c'est ça aussi c'est que
tu tu le dis toi-même g si tu n'es plus
le même et que même dans ton
comportement physique tu fais attention
à ne plus sortir dans la
rue c'est c'est difficile d'en faire
abstraction aussi lorsque tu tu es ici
et lorsque tu es ici tu te dis j'ai été
violent là-dessus hier je peut-être qu'
aller molo demain donc bah pardon mais
je pense que ça nous traverse tous
l'esprit et si c'est ça c'est là où ils
ont gagné bien s merci on n pas con
merci en tout cas qu'est- excuse-moi
Greg bon ça va tu es pas trop stress pas
du tout ouais ça va tranquille non
jamais de la vie non pas trop stressé
racheter un scooter ou pas mais ils me
l'ont retrouvé mon scooter ouis tu vas
le reprendre le même je vais garder mon
scooter bien sûr ouais pourqui je vais
m'arrêter de vivre moi pour ces gens-là
ah ben alors je fais quoi Siri alors
dis-moi ben donne-moi une solution alors
je fais quoi bah tu prends un ch
j'arrête de vivre alors je peux te
ramener moi je peux t'amener je peux
c'est vrai tu veux me ramener me ramener
ouais vas-y tu veux m'amener me ramener
fais ça merci Greg en tout cas d'avoir
été avec nous merci Michel Mar tout de
suite c'est mon jile sur ces merci